en medio de una profunda confrontación
entre el gobierno y el partido del poder
morena Por una parte y la autoridad
electoral y los partidos de oposición
por otra el senado de la República
aprobó con 72 votos a favor de 50 en
contra un paquete de modificaciones a
las leyes electorales conocidas como el
Plan B que fundamentalmente reducen la
estructura del Instituto Nacional
electoral el argumento del presidente
López Obrador autor de estas iniciativas
y de su partido Morena es que buscan
hacer más eficiente y reducir los costos
de los procesos electorales abatiendo
esta burocracia dorada que argumentan
priva en el instituto en contraste el
presidente de este instituto Lorenzo
Córdoba ha advertido en reiteradas
ocasiones que este paquete de reformas
son regresivas que plantean el riesgo de
que de nueva cuenta el gobierno pueda
influir intervenir en los procesos
electorales Por qué Porque debilita
mucho la de este organismo autónomo pues
implicará la reducción del 80% del
servicio profesional electoral es decir
la gente que trabaja en el INE
elaborando las cartografías electorales
previendo la instalación de las casillas
para que la gente pueda ir a votar
emitiendo las credenciales de elector en
fin todo lo que conlleva la organización
de un proceso confiable por su parte los
partidos de oposición el pan el PRD el
pri han advertido que Tan pronto como El
Ejecutivo que ya tiene en su cancha
estas leyes las promulgue acudirán a
impugnarlas ante la suprema corte de
justicia de la nación de modo tal que
serán los ministros quienes tengan la
última palabra sobre si estas
modificaciones son o no constitucionales